I think there's a whole side of divorce
that is not spoken about and I think for
about 50 years we've been hearing the
woman's point of view and okay women
have gone through some stuff not much
these days but some stuff and we've
heard you but I think at some point we
got to listen to the men and what the
men have to say and really guys the
quality of wives on the market is subpar
it is bad I I don't I think I know maybe
five traditional women that actually
obey their husbands and when the quality
of the wife on the market this is the
Christian conservative women means
having a nanny work a hundred hours a
week to raise your kids for you and you
accuse your husband of abuse 24 7. um I
I think we're in we're in tough time